chaque nuit et ce depuis qu'il a
emménagé ici en 2019 il entend ce bruit
devenu insupportable à l'époque il y
avait que des retraités maintenant il y
a des jeunes travailleurs est-ce que
aussi cette dame ou ses enfants peuvent
comprendre l'inverse aussi que cette
nuit et que ça nous
c'est pénible si on peut pas dormir
pourquoi je devrais subir
et pour la retraité de 92 ans pas
question de déplacer ces petits animaux
ailleurs comme lui a proposé le maire
je suis toute seule j'ai 92 ans j'ai du
mal à marcher je suis vieille les
poissons et les grenouilles de
distraction ce qui met aussi en colère
Colette c'est la venue des gendarmes
chez elle il y a quelques jours à la
suite de plusieurs plaintes de voisins
c'est de pouvoir avant tout les c'est
d'avoir avant tout un les pieds dans la
gadoue ou deux les yeux en face des
trous l'été dernier la consommation de
la commune était trois fois plus élevée
que la moyenne nationale le problème
serait derrière cette porte celle de la
maison de Silvio Berlusconi ancien chef
du gouvernement italien ou encore
derrière celle de l'ancien roi belge
Albert II au total à Châteauneuf-Grasse
cinq propriétés des résidences
secondaires souvent avec plus de 20
hectares de terrain sont pointés du
doigt et questionnent les riverains
étant un consommateur de pastilles
j'aime beaucoup
non parce que c'est merveilleux c'est
des petits producteurs non mais c'est
très classe c'est très bon mais j'adore
le ricard aussi j'adore le pastis 51
alors simplement les vrais consommateurs
de passis nous ne mettons pas d'eau de
source d'eau de en bouteille mais de
l'eau de robinet c'est-à-dire que parce
que la tradition c'est d'avoir un une
petite jarre avec de l'eau et que rempli
au robinet comme dans la soupe aux choux
alors qu'est-ce que tu en penses c'est
pas mal il y a qu'un truc qui va pas
c'est toi et là
des arrêtés préfectoraux un peu des
restrictions mais certains propriétaires
vont jusqu'à consommer 2000 mètres cubes
d'eau par semaine soit la consommation à
l'année de 17 familles cette agriculteur
lui a perdu 85% de sa récolte mais cette
année encore il devra limiter l'arrosage
voilà le goutte-goutte il est dans le
tuyau xD il aimerait de nouveaux recours
légaux
tout simplement et de laisser juste la
quantité d'eau dont on a besoin pour
l'alimentation humaine voilà pour son
hygiène pour boire ce qui est tout à
fait normal elle s'est perdue sa voiture
c'est enlisée dans la boue elle avait
pas de réseau ça marchait pas elle
pouvait pas appeler les secours et donc
résultat il est resté 5 jours dans le
coin et pour survivre bah fallait faire
avec les moyens du bord et les moyens du
bord c'était des petits bonbons des
sucettes en l'occurrence donc bien sucré
et la bouteille de vin qu'elle avait
dans le coffre elle elle voit pas en
temps normal
[Musique]
mélange à travers ce morceau il entend
bien rétablir la vérité sur ce
département à l'image parfois peu
flatteuse comme il valait ce camion tu
as de mes parents ou
je vais vous le dire avec cette
honnêteté qui me caractérise on s'en
tape un peu voilà
les clichés à mon sens c'est beaucoup
l'effet divers Grégory etc souvent on a
une vision pas séiste de ce départ de ce
département de cet endroit alors que
pour moi ça peut être le futur c'est ici
qui peut se passer des initiatives
locales plus écolo moi c'est ça que j'ai
envie de dire on n'est pas dans une
région pacéiste on est dans un
département d'avenir au contraire une
odeur département les habitants n'en
n'avaient jamais entendu
on parle
d'Île-de-France et tout mais pas des
vols
comment c'était en quoi en quoi alors
je ne vais pas la faire on ne se
comprend pas
le camion c'était un quoi quelle marque
ah quelle marque Citroën Jumper Citroën
c'est mieux continuons reprenons notre
cas pas de chance
moi je t'aime aussi
depuis bien bien plus longtemps que lui
c'est vrai
sa liste de filles est déjà remplie mais
il lui manque deux garçons alors dès
qu'elle aperçoit un beau jeune homme
elle met le paquet comment tu t'appelles
ça pourrait être mon fils
tout de suite
est-ce que la différence d'âge est
réellement importante
il y en a un qui va pas être content là
est-ce que vous savez ce qui se passe en
ce moment à Hiroshima
si vous me dites c'est ça qui se passe
quelque chose d'important sur les trois
quatre derniers jours j'avoue je mange
et je bois cinéma
[Applaudissements]
Grande-Bretagne mais pas que l'Allemagne
la Grande-Bretagne l'Italie et la
Pologne sont des pays qui soutiennent le
terrorisme en donnant des armes Zelenski
il faut les reconnaître en tant que
participant au conflit et frappé tous
ces pays là où c'est nécessaire nous
avons des missiles il faut les leur
envoyer
des chercheurs américains ont donc tenté
l'expérience sur 18 perroquets de 13
espèces différentes résultats 147 appels
spontanés limitées à deux par jour et
par animal assez pour en tirer des
conclusions positives sur le besoin de
lien social vital chez le perroquet
quand ils sont ensemble
is bagarre il se chamaille voilà c'est
la ils vivent leur vie de perroquet le M
Nathalie elle ne demande qu'à être
décalée la moule
on dessale pas une moule elle parle
d'expérience